Ned Fulmer is no longer one of the try
guys we
can we touch a long way after
Revelations the married father of two
had an affair with a co-worker in a
statement shared to Instagram Ned admits
to having a quote consensual workplace
relationship now we have our own
production company we have a staff of 15
people Ned says quote families should
have always been my priority but I lost
Focus adding quote I'm sorry for any
pain that my actions may have caused
earlier on Tuesday longtime fans got a
shocking announcement from the group's
social media accounts quote Ned Fulmer
is no longer working with the try guys
as a result of a thorough internal
review we do not see a path forward
together we thank you for your support
as we navigate this change so how do we
get here what it means to be a try guy
well Ned co-founded the group back in
2014. alongside Partners Keith Zach and
Eugene fast forward to 2022 the try guys
boast a YouTube channel with over 7
million subscribers
you know I don't know that I fully
realized how much of a thing we are in
their latest claim to fame a Food
Network TV series
that was hot but lately eagle died fans
noticed signs of Trouble behind the
scenes after Ned wasn't featured in the
group's past three videos well we're
finally doing a video I never wanted to
try and while there's rumors of Plenty
Of Who Ned's Affair was with nothing's
confirmed for now I was still not even
comfortable being a try guy yeah
moving forward the outside member says
quote the only thing that matters right
now is my marriage and my children and
that's where I am going to focus my
attention the Scandal comes soon after
Ned celebrated his 10th wedding
anniversary yeah yes cheers honey cheers
his wife Ariel shares a message of her
own quote nothing is more important to
me and Ned than our family all we
request right now is that you respect
our privacy for the sake of our kids
[Music]